pour la première fois en sentant le
tunnel du mont royal voit la lumière du
jour
c'est ici en plein centre ville pour
passer les trains de banlieue de deux
montagnes de mascouche que le rem
circulera en 2022
à coups de marteau piqueur une centaine
de mètres de l'ancienne arche en béton
du tunnel sont en train d'être démoli
pour faire place à la nouvelle citation
mais guînes du train électrique save est
à peu près l'équivalent d'une bâtisse de
trois étages qui vont être bâtis
chimiques et le meygal college il faut
faire en sorte que c'est une station
complètement souterraines dont les accès
vont être via le métro et violet centre
eaton de montréal cross un chantier du
rem parmi une vingtaine en cours dans la
région de montréal
le secteur le plus avancé et sur la
rive-sud à brossard
la branche sud sera d'ailleurs la
première à être inauguré possiblement
dès la fin 2021
on voit ici la nouvelle station du
quartier au dessus de l'autoroute 10 à
la hauteur du dix30
c'est sur ce tronçon de trois kilomètres
et demi que débuteront bientôt les
premiers essais du renne cet automne
vraiment c'est le moment où on souhaite
commencer donc recevoir les voitures
commencer les tests
c'est ce qu'on avait lancé on garde le
cap sur l'automne dans l'ouest de l'île
ou si la construction du rem avant 8 le
long de l'autoroute 40
six des 14 km de structures aériennes à
construire vers sainte anne de bellevue
sont terminés ici comme dans griffintown
les piliers ont un impact important dans
le paysage
c'est un petit peu plus haut que ce
qu'on s'attendait que c'était supposé
passer en dessous au début mais je pense
que ça va je pense qu'il ya des
structures qui sont moins belle que ça
dans le coin la facture finale du rem
évaluées pour l'instant à 6 milliards et
demi de dollars pourrait encore grimper
en raison de la fermeture des chantiers
le printemps dernier et impact énorme de
la pandémie à dorval
aéroports de montréal qui paie sa propre
regard pas perdu tellement d'argent
qu'il demande 600 millions de dollars
des gouvernements pour pouvoir aller de
l'avant nous l'objectif c'est partir
prochainement un tunnelier pour
justement atteint l'aéroport faut savoir
que pour nous cette façon-là de
l'aéroport de morale
très important c'est une liaison qui est
attendu les effets de la pandémie
nuisent aussi beaucoup au transport
collectif et ont donné un élan au
télétravail
la caisse de dépôt maître d'oeuvre du
projet et elle inquiète pour son
investissement
quand on regarde cette perspective là à
long terme sur le justement sur
plusieurs dizaines d'années 50 ans
peut-être jusqu'à 100 ans le règne de la
projet structure a un qui doit salle
immense atout pour les usagers de la
région certes mais ce n'est pas à court
terme que le rem remplira le bas de
laine des québécois ici gens se lassent
et cloutier radio canada montréal